And now for the answer.
Well, of course, there is no real answer to that quiz.
Any answer is fine in here.
However, a few comments on the individual options.
If you're a fan of Sherlock Holmes in solving puzzles and all,
this unit is right for you--as is debugging, for that matter.
If you think that Sherlock Holmes is outdated,
well, try and read one of the old stories and see how outdated they really are
or check out one of the most recent adaptations of Sherlock Holmes.
If you find Sherlock Holmes annoying
because his way of reasoning is obnoxious
or showing off his super-smartness,
that's probably correct, but I think that Arthur Conan Doyle
actually wanted to portray Sherlock Holmes as somebody who's not entirely likable.
Finally, Sherlock Who?
Here's something to discover for you. Enjoy.